und wir schauen jetzt auf den gipfel der
jungen unternehmer dabei geht es um eine
branchenübergreifende
interessenvertretung für familien und
eigentümer unternehmer bis 40 jahre und
bei ihrem gipfel heute in berlin werden
sie mit hochkarätigen gästen aus
wirtschaft und politik diskutieren unter
anderem mit wirtschaftsminister peter
altmaier und mit ihrer kampagne restart
deutschland und wollen sie in diesem
wahlkampf für eine unternehmerische und
generationengerechte zukunft kämpfen und
darüber möchte ich jetzt gerne sprechen
mit der bundesvorsitzende des verbands
tannhäuser ich grüße sie
einen schönen guten morgen frau wie
sieht denn dieser kampf genau aus und
was bedeutet oder was braucht es für
einen restart deutschland
ja wir alle wissen in zehn tagen wählt
deutschland eine neue bundesregierung
und bei den jungen unternehmern setzen
wir uns intensiv mit den wahlprogrammen
der parteien auseinander und sehen auch
wie unterschiedlich die ideen für staat
wirtschaft und gesellschaft sind und mit
der die parteien in diesem jahr ins
rennen gehen und es ist wirklich eine
richtungsentscheidung von der wir stehen
und deswegen bringen wir uns als junge
unternehmer verstärkt in die politische
debatte ein so auch heute und wir setzen
uns ein für mehr wirtschaftskompetenz in
der neuen bundesregierung und das
bedeutet für uns ganz konkret dass ihr
politische klarheit brauchen und dass
auch die spd und die linken sollte es zu
einer rot rot grünen regierung kommen
die spd auch der linken ganz klar die
rote karte zeigt und hier auch eine
koalition aus schließt denn wie sie es
gerade schon erwähnt haben wir brauchen
einen restart für deutschland wir haben
jetzt während der korona krise gemerkt
wie viele große themen auf der straße
liegen geblieben sind sei es das thema
infrastruktur digitaler breitbandausbau
digitale verwaltung da brauchen wir
wirklich ein digitales wirtschaftswunder
und vor allem auch in zukunft eine
prioritätensetzung wofür will
steuergelder verwenden laut einer
umfrage die ihr verband mit in auftrag
gegeben hat würden familienunternehmer
bei rot grün rot weniger investieren was
ist denn da die größte sorge
ja tatsächlich wir haben eine umfrage
durchgeführt bei der herauskam dass über
drei viertel der unternehmer ihre
investitionsvorhaben in deutschland
zurück stellen würden falls eine rot rot
grüne regierung kommt über 94 prozent
der familienunternehmen befürchten dass
das internationale image des
wirtschaftsstandorts deutschland sehr
negativ verändert würde was enorme
auswirkungen auch auf die
direktinvestitionen hätte und
gleichzeitig wollen wir auch für einen
erfolgreichen restart jetzt werben weil
diese umfragewerte sind natürlich
erschreckend das würde natürlich
bedeuten für deutschland und den
deutschen mittelstand es wird weniger
investiert die unternehmen sind weniger
wettbewerbsfähig das wirkt sich dann am
ersten schritt auf die löhne aus und
würde am schluss dann auch arbeitsplätze
gefährden und wir wollen von seiten der
jungen unternehmer heute im rahmen
unseres politischen gipfels in berlin
auf diese ja auf diese auswirkungen
möglichen auswirkungen hinweisen und die
politik wachrütteln und ihnen sagen ihr
müsst ein bündnis mit der
wirtschaftsfeindlichen linken
ausschließen damit wir auch als junge
nachfolge-generation als junge familien
unternehmen und traditionsunternehmen
auch eine zukunft hier in deutschland
haben steuern runter und bürokratie
abbauen das ist ja die hauptbotschaft
des cdu wirtschaftsprogramms wenn sie
daran hätten mitarbeiten können wäre
dieses programm denn genauso ausgefallen
oder was müsste da anders sein
tatsächlich hat ja die cdu mit laschet
und friedrich merz ein neues programm
aufgesetzt ich kann sagen wir begrüßen
das programm es ist ein wichtiges signal
an die unternehmer in diesem land denn
die cdu bekennt sich in ihrem papier
klar zur sozialen marktwirtschaft das
ist genau das was wir jetzt brauchen das
ist in diesen zeiten wirklich wichtig
diese säulen der sozialen
marktwirtschaft auch wie freiheit
wettbewerb und eigentum immer stärker
auch in den fokus zu nehmen weil das
haben wir in den letzten jahren leider
vermisst und die cdu legt sich auch
darauf ist keine substanz steuern wie
eine vermögenssteuer einer
vermögensabgabe einzuführen oder auch
steuern zu erhöhen und das ist eine ganz
klare absage auch gegenüber den ideen
mit vermögenssteuer vermögensabgabe was
die anderen parteien haben und das ist
jetzt in dieser zeit nach der korona
pandemie wo sich viele deutsche
familienunternehmen gerade erst aus der
krise herausarbeiten
ein unglaublich wichtiges signal denn
wir brauchen nicht noch mehr belastung
weil das würde viele unternehmen
tatsächlich ja die vielen unternehmen
tatsächlich schaden aber irgendwie muss
das kann sich auch schon finanziert
werden zurück zur schuldenbremse und
steuerentlastungen wie soll das denn
dann zusammen gehen
ja also tatsächlich in der debatte
beobachten wir ja entweder nur der eine
weg steuererhöhungen oder der zweite weg
denn die schuldenbremse aufzulösen wir
von seiten der jungen unternehmer sagen
wir wollen den dritten weg gehen und das
ist wirklich die ärmel hochkrempeln und
auf wachstum setzen wir müssen jetzt
tatsächlich die rahmenbedingungen
schaffen die entlastungen schaffen für
den deutschen mittelstand für die
unternehmen im land damit sie
wirtschaften können weil das war vielen
unternehmen tatsächlich während corona
nicht möglich während deren log downs
viele unternehmen haben die
eigenkapitalreserven aufgebraucht und
jetzt müssen wir tatsächlich wieder ins
wirtschaften kommen wir müssen nach
vorne blicken und wir müssen in diese
richtung alle fesseln sprengen dass uns
das auch möglich ist sagt susanne
rössler vom verband junger unternehmer
vielen dank für dieses gespräch
sehr gerne